[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin rhodia jette pas la cote de la
dette et à des coûts sera de machos
djakpa la clope perd le contrôle on va
regarder la bande annonce dans un
instant mais aimer jet jet plus vous qui
je veux qu'ils réagissent avec nous ce
sera jeff vous connaissez un petit peu
et ça a commencé la drogue c'est trop
cool
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez nous avons un commentaire ce
rouge c'est pas possible
commentaires sur valérie bénaïm fait
plaisir jean marc ayrault
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez conscience que vous êtes
complètement siphonnée il ya également
jean michel maire qui est derrière
alors vous connaissez pas vous
connaissez tous le monde jorisch albert
vous en pensez quoi
on a fait des soirées ensemble mais je
t'attends parler on a en procès avec
jean michel mr cd quoi comme soirée un
truc chelou un peu celle où avec des
masques et touchante arrête plus tard
d'accord vous connaissez gilbert bel
ouais
allez c'est pas tout ouais je connais
fatou gaye sarr et ont semblé en entrant
et vous vous faisiez l'amour comme une
fois par semaine par exemple par semaine
ou par jour oui je sais que c'est la
grille la cuisine mais je cuisine c'est
très bien on s'en fou non
alors voir jusqu'où je voulais rentrer
des boulettes et une culotte
oui vous êtes là vous êtes mal tombée
via des chats quoi qu'est ce que vous
mettez les boulets de recul
jeff c'est la première fois que vous
venez dans touche pas à mon poste les
personnes que vous que vous préférez
plus qu'une autre autour de la table ou
pas revient un vigile vergès à ceux qui
nous aiment pas ouais vous a dit qu'il
nous aimait pas les noirs c'est vrai
quoi vous à vous les aimez pas bon et
j'ai trouvé que par rapport à kenji une
fois c'était un petit peu déplacé donc
j'avais dit sur un souci c'est vrai aux
nrj music awards sa vraie voix quand il
parle bien qu'il sépare le nom m'échappe
fait le mec du son en régie chez des
oreilles bien il faut
c'est quoi pour vous une bonne émission
de télé jean marc haas et à celle là
déjà ses finances du canada dry sur la
gueule pour ça mais je gardais vous
posez votre question vous herbe au soir
cyril hanouna de dauphiné libéré le plus
souvent possible avec la même toujours
non mais elles comprennent mais ça va
pas non elle peut pousser à tuer tout le
temps dans quelle est sa méthode dans
google
oui c'est un bon comédien
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus racine avec les femmes depuis
que vous passez à la télé ou pas c'est
pareil j'en veux dire moi je n'y 14 h
il est comment patrick sébastien dans la
vie il est il est vieux père ont touché
à l'antenne il se passe quoi dans les
loges du plus grand cabaret du monde
magath intrigue qui fait hélicoptères
axa be
[Rires]
vous feriez une émission comme secret
story ou pas ouais pourquoi pas on
connaît ton secret lotis les endroits
dans le cul d'un singe on connaît pensez
quoi des programmes de télé réalité
bon moi je suis pas fan moi j'adore est
toujours des gonzesses à poil les trucs
là entrée sur d8 j'ai vu ils sont tous à
poils à la c'est nouveau ça ça va
arriver c'est monsieur